Hi everyone, in this section, let's go and take a look at the editing tools in Unreal
to be able to craft and build and add to our game worlds.
So let's get started.
So we're going to be using the modeling tools here for editing.
And in there we can do several things.
We can do sculpting if we wanted to, modeling tools for quick sculpting, shading, general
sculpting like DynaSculpt, pivot changes, and even UV editing.
Let's go and jump into Unreal and I'll show you what I'm talking about.
So we're going to stay within the same scene that we worked with the in class project with
our world part N EX example.
And in here, I just grabbed this, any old piece right there, I found where he lived,
and I created a duplicate.
Now the reason why I'm doing that is whenever you change the pivot of something already
set in your scene, or even sculpt on it, it's going to affect all the instances in
your environment.
So you want to make sure that you make a copy.
If you don't make a copy, it will affect everything.
But if he's a fresh recruit, he just got imported into Unreal, I can freely change
the pivot and move things around sculpt, or changes geometry or UVs, and everything
will be right as rain in the world, because he's the only one that exists.
But again, if you want to use these tools with items already in the environment,
you want to actually find where that object is.
And with that object, you want to make sure that you make a duplicate of it.
And when you make a duplicate of it, you want to make sure that you're only working
with that duplicate.
And you can drag them into your scene.
And with that in your scene, then you can run the adjustments as needed.
Otherwise, if you do not make a duplicate, if you make pivot changes on something already
existing in place, it's going to affect all of them, it may send that piece of geometry
to Fresno, or Africa, or it'll get it'll completely mess it up.
And you'll have to go and re manually edit that again, which is kind of a pain in
the butt.
So just keep that in mind.
So I have an asset here, we're going to go to the modeling section, you can see already
have it up.
And in here, we can do several things.
One, we can control UVs.
So if I needed to change the UVs in any way, I can easily do so by going to my UV
editor.
Now the UV editor tool is fantastic.
In here, it shows us our quick access to these tools, we can also go to the menus in
here and decide what we want to look at.
So in this particular case, we want to say, hey, you know, I want to take a look at
the display.
And in the display, I want to display the background in here, I can choose checkerboard,
or I can decide that I want to use the texture to be able to see the texture that I built
for it already.
I'm hitting the Alt and left key to navigate, it gets a little weird inside the viewport,
but it's nothing that can be managed.
So in here, underneath checkerboard background display, I can choose the particular texture.
And with that texture, I can load that texture in my scene, and then have it available
to be able to be seen in my outline or my layout for my UVs.
Now if you want to move, you simply click on the move tools for each shell that you
select.
And you can lock them into place.
If you want to say, hey, man, I really want to lock that in my scale, or my location, all
that can be used to your advantage.
If you need to, it's really great to be able to work with these, and you'll see
them in place locked as you move around.
So that is the UVs.
Let's go and look at some more tools that we have, we're gonna say no, we do not want
to make any changes.
Let's go to the X form.
Now the X form is also crucial when working with instances, such as the pivot, like I mentioned,
the Edit Pivot tool is fantastic.
And again, remember, I'm working with a copy.
So if you're in the scene, duplicate the assets, any of them in here, and drag them
into your scene again, so that way you don't send like the bridge or the tower
or the base somewhere far away from your environment.
So I can choose center, bottom, top, and I can even apply to all LODs, snap drag position,
snap drag rotation.
And I can choose exactly where I want these to go, which is pretty great.
And because the old school pivot method was a little bit cumbersome, used to go to
pivot, set your pivot offset here, set pivot as offset, it was a little bit weird.
But here, this works pretty well and quickly, especially if you bring your asset, maybe
you're under the crunch time, and then you forgot to get the pivot set in Maya, or you
have it set a particular way as in a group of assets already built, you can bring them
in and then reset the pivot as long as they come in fresh and are already in the world.
Now, if they're already in the world, again, emphasize, you need to make a duplicate.
I'm going to cancel on this.
We also have such tools for the deform area, such as the lattice tool.
I happen to love this tool, it works really great.
We can do soft deformations, and by default, the deform rumbles isn't on.
But this is really helpful.
If I was to go in here, you want to make sure it's on, I can move these around and
make sure that my normals and my textures don't get too warped around.
Now if they do, you'll have to go back in the UV tool and adjust those shells and
edit those things accordingly.
So keep those things in mind.
You can choose how your gizmo is going to be digested.
And overall, this is a great tool.
There's also create if you need to, but I prefer to make things right now in the DCC,
but it's not limited to.
Now you can also remesh an item too, if you need.
So let's get out of this for a second.
We'll get out of the lattice tool, we're going to remesh for a second here.
Got to hit cancel.
In here under remesh, I can choose whether I want to go in here and simplify it, or
remesh it.
This can happen if your game decides, your game director says, hey, I want to bump up
this game and make it a lot larger than what it is.
And in doing so, we want to use Nanite, or maybe you're not going to mobile anymore,
you're making a PC version.
You want to remesh in that case, because using Nanite, Nanite prefers the higher poly
versus the lower poly.
So I would run a remesh, I would make sure I set my target count.
Again, this is an approximation, like your regular DCCs, like Maya's remesh tool, as well
as the 3D Studio Max, it gives you an approximated amount of triangle count in there.
And then it does a pretty darn good job.
But if you do need to save the lower one, I recommend, again, running this with a copy
of the original so that you can have a higher poly version if you need it, and a lower
poly version to reference.
It's really up to you.
But if it's already living in the world, and you need to remesh it, and you only need certain
ones remeshed, and there's some in the background, I advise making a copy first, running it
and seeing if it's what you need or want, and that way it doesn't affect all the versions
in your environment, and you keep the original clean by itself.
So those are really great tools for that.
Well that's pretty much all we're going to cover in this particular section.
In the next sections, we're going to be looking at lighting, as well as material optimization.
Thanks again.